dieses jahr wird es anders dieses jahr
nehme ich mir wirklich mal vor haben sie
so was so einen guten vorsatz bild hilft
ihnen auf jeden fall in diesem jahr das
dann auch wirklich einzuhalten das zu
schaffen mit unserem sparfuchs mit frank
ochse was genau ist diese bild aktion ja
wirklich eine einzigartige aktion
gestern war teilnahmeschluss viele bild
leser und zuschauer haben sich bei uns
beworben und sagen wir wollen endlich
unsere vorsätze auch umsetzen wir
sichten gerade noch mal wen wir dann
auch tatsächlich begleiten und sinn und
zweck ist es dass wir ihnen oder den
gewinnern dann helfen wirklich dran zu
bleiben mit dem experten mit guten wort
mit motivation so dass vielleicht
wirklich dann mitte februar vielleicht
das ziel schon erreicht ist und dann
belohnen wir dieses durchhaltevermögen
mit 1000 euro und du hast uns ja auch
einen beitrag mitgebracht hast uns eine
frau mitgebracht die sich einen ganz
besonderen vorsatz sich etwas ganz
besonderes sie möchte nämlich mehr in
die höhe mehr in die freiheit nach oben
genau wir haben nämlich frau töne sie
hat sich bewährt gesagt mit ich leide so
unter flugangst ich fliege zwar aber das
ist für mich immer mit großen qualen
verbunden und wir wollen mit ihr jetzt
darüber sprechen wie sie damit umgeht
und wir haben auch einen experten wir
schauen einmal ganz kurz energie sich
frau töne bei uns beworben hat ihr guter
vorsatz das hat sie gesagt das schaffe
ich
hallo ich bin martina thöne und ich habe
angst wenn ich genau da drin bin so
entspannt wie hier sitze ich im flugzeug
nämlich nicht ich reise zwar total gerne
aber es weiß halt leider auch immer die
flugangst mitunter schon seit 20 jahren
deshalb ist ein guter vorsatz für 2020
ich möchte endlich meine flugangst
bekämpfen
also endlich hoch hinaus und das oder
angst und jetzt ist sie uns auch
zugeschaltet frau herzlich willkommen
bei uns wie läuft es denn mit dem
fliegen wie geht es ihnen denn ansonsten
wenn sie einen flieger besteigen
na also ich werde schon nervös wenn ich
jetzt ans fliegen denke also ich wie
gesagt ich reise total gerne aber die
flugangst ist immer dabei und ich weiß
das gilt so ein bisschen als
luxusproblem und man sagt dann ganz oft
achtern fahrdorf flieht doch nicht reist
doch nicht aber das kann ja auch keine
lösung sein ich denke wir haben alle
ängste manche fahren ich gerne auto
andere haben angst vorm zahnarzt beim
jesus die flugangst und ich denke man
sollte da dran bleiben und man sollte
immer versuchen ja an den ängsten
aufzuarbeiten
wann sind sie zuletzt geflogen und wie
äußert sich dann die flugangst also
nehmen sie vorher ein schlückchen damit
besser geht und schlaftabletten doch wie
äußert sich das bei ihnen
ja zuletzt geflogen bin ich im oktober
also werden corona jetzt tatsächlich
lange nicht weil ich denke dass ich
jetzt auch nicht angesagt mit den
intelligenten und der pandemie aber
wichtig ist oder mir ist immer wichtig
dass ich nicht jahrelang nicht fliegen
weil ich glaube dann wäre tatsächlich
das risiko dass ich tatsächlich dann
nicht mehr einsteigen also ich bin im
oktober geflogen und ich versuche mich
immer selbst zu motivieren ich habe aber
schon alles durch in 20 25 jahren ich
lese viel
dann wünsche ich mir immer dass freunde
mich unterstützen und auch mal jemand
auf die schulter klopft und sagt hast du
toll gemacht
genommen habe ich tatsächlich einmal was
aber ich bin die fraktion also ich nehme
eigentlich nicht mal eine
kopfschmerztablette schmerztabletten nie
ich habe es tatsächlich einmal auf
ärztlichen rat mit wahlen jungen
versucht und war da sehr erstaunt weil
es valium hat überhaupt nicht
angeschlagen also mein körper hat
überhaupt nicht reagiert und dann sagte
die ärztin später daran sieht man dass
sie wirklich sehr große flugangst haben
weil wenn der körper gar nicht reagiert
dann hilft da wirklich auch kein
medikament und da hilft dann wirklich
einfach nur sich selbst zu überwinden
und dann doch einzusteigen frau töne wie
ist das wenn man sie im flieger erlebt
ist es dann so dass knacken oder das
anschnallzeichen geht an oder es
vibriert was macht ihnen da am meisten
angst wir machen die turbulenzen angst
also flugangst hat ja viele facetten und
wer keine flugangst hat denkt oft
dahinter steckt die reale angst dass man
abstürzen könnte das ist es nicht also
manche haben höhenangst manchem
platzangst dann gibt es natürlich auch
in luftiger höhe das beifahrer syndrom
manche haben die kontrolle zu verlieren
manchem angst vor der technik weil das
natürlich auch etwas ungewohntes ist man
weiß nicht was passiert bei mir sind es
schlechte erfahrungen also ich hatte bei
den ersten flügen keine flugangst hat
mir da auch noch nicht so gedanken
gemacht als kind und dann kam so als
damit so um die 20 kamen dann mehrere
flüge die waren wirklich turbulent und
turbulenzen sind natürlich auch etwas
subjektives also für den 1
der eine nimmt schon leichtes wackeln
als turbulent war bei mir ist immer so
ein gradmesser wenn sich die
flugbegleiterinnen und flugbegleiter
hinsetzen müssen und es wirklich wackelt
und man dieses gefühl hat auch
abzusacken und jetzt ist es so wenn ich
jetzt fliege dass ich einfach angst habe
wieder so ein flug zu erleben und wieder
diese situation zu haben ich bin so ein
optimistischer mensch das glas ist
eigentlich immer halb voll
aber wenn man halt mehrere flüge erlebt
hat die für einen selbst wirklich
schlimm waren dann
reist dieses gefühl immer mit und es ist
diese angst wieder einen solchen flug zu
erleben ich kann das total verstehen ich
glaube fast sie könnten ein schwieriger
fall sein weil sie ja alles schon so gut
reflektieren weil sie ja schon alles
machen sie fliegen ja sie bleiben ja
dran sie machen sich so viel gedanken
wie sie haben schon so viel ausprobiert
also sprechen wir aber mit jemand sich
selbst eben doch und da sprechen wir mit
jemandem es gibt raub töne der das
wirklich beurteilen kann nämlich mit dem
psychologen martin rosenbauer der uns
jetzt zugeschaltet ist ich grüße sie
herzlich herr roosen lauer und ich habe
gerade gesagt das klingt mir noch ein
bisschen schwierigen fall vielleicht ist
es das aber gar nicht haben sie eine
schon eine lösung parat für frau töne
und ihre flugangst ja schön gegen morgen
allerseits erstmal also natürlich gibt
es für die meisten probleme die menschen
so mitbringen zum psychologen eine
lösung das thema ist meistens versuchen
die menschen mit dem kopf so zu sagen
weil sich die angst im emotions zentrum
nur viele jahre auch stark aufgeladen
hat versuchen die dagegen anzukämpfen
versuchen die angst zu negieren dadurch
geht man diese sechs abwertung nach und
angst aber nun mal ist nicht nur etwas
das aus vielen gedanken besteht sondern
es ist primär erst mal ein gefühl und es
hat im angstzentrum in unserem
menschliche gehirne sehr hohe ladung und
je mehr sie das unterdrücken wie auch
tränen die sie nicht weinen zum beispiel
bei einem trauerfall wird sich das immer
mehr aufladen und dann werden die gegen
sie ankämpfen die trainer oder die angst
was sie also jetzt die frau töne hat das
gedanklich alles wunderbar vorbereitet
deswegen kann ich das schön wie sehr die
an sich schon gearbeitet hat und jetzt
auch schon gesprochen also so als die 20
mitte 20 war gab es diese schwierigen
flügel diese hatte und jetzt wäre
vielmehr die frage also angst ist ein
gefühl das kann sehr stark werden und
kann auch die kontrolle über den körper
übernehmen wie bauen sie diese angst und
dieser jungen frau von damals eine
brücke ja und dann gehen sie mehr über
das gefühl und können der jungen frau
die hand reichen der jungfrau sagen
mitteilen kommunizieren sie doch angst
haben sie reichen mir die hand und
nehmen sie in die arme so in etwa könnte
man vorgehen das wäre dann ein
systemischer integrative ansatz als es
weg haben zu wollen
gibt es denn auch sachen tipps so ganz
pragmatische tipps man steht jetzt vor
dem flugzeug ich persönlich finde es ja
auch total normal ich meine man wird mit
nanoröhren himmel geschossen ich finde
es ganz gut wenn man da ein bisschen
kritisch dran geht und ich sage sogar
keinen blick also ich bin da ganz bei
ihnen freut wenn aber geht es in so ein
paar tipps wenn man jetzt einsteigt und
man merkt oh gott ich kriege schon
schütze gerne mein puls geht hoch die
man machen kann paar atemübungen ein
paar sachen wie man vielleicht auch die
ganzen emotionen was in deinem kopf
abgeht so ein bisschen austricksen kann
genau also das eine ist natürlich dass
sie versuchen starke ablenken dazu
finden wo die wo die angst dann quasi
innerlich sagt das finde ich viel
interessanter als das ich jetzt die
ganze zeit luster angst zu haben
anfliegen starke ablenker können seien
eine bestimmte musik die jemand total
gerne hört die quasi die ganze
aufmerksamkeit auf sagt oder eine
geschichte wurde das board tv und
manchmal wenn die angst dann aber
trotzdem stärker ist dann kommt man
nicht daran vorbei also dass alles
natürlich sie können trenkel annehmen zu
können da war gläser wein trinken das
hilft ihr auch aber wenn du es auch
nicht hilft dann kommen sie nicht daran
vorbei mit der angst in einen dialog zu
gehen ja also nicht mehr so zu sagen
dass ich immer weiter innerlich
aufzuspalten dieses spalten haben wir
auch gerade noch bei anderen
gesellschaftlichen diskussionen sondern
um den dialog miteinander zu kommen die
starke erwachsene frau wendet sich der
als liebevoll czuma das nennt man innere
kind weiter
können sie frau töne mit der
beschreibung mit der angst in den dialog
zu gehen auch mit all den handbewegungen
die herzen höher gemacht hat schon was
anfangen kann das schon helfen oder
zumindest eher an also das ist das ist
auch das was ich mache also ich sage
auch immer allen das was am meisten
hilft wenn man ängste hat ist dass man
erstens selbst es annimmt und das mache
ich also
und dass man eben daran arbeitet also
was gerade gesagt wurde kann ich total
nachempfinden also mir hilft nur eins
fotografieren ich sitze gerne am fenster
und gucke raus ich habe unendlich viele
fotos wenn sie auf mein handy schauen
könnte man meinen ich fliege jeden tag
weil ich hunderte von bildern machen
während eines flugs das ist das einzige
was mich ablenkt ich kann keine musik
hören ich kann keinen film gucken ich
kann mich nicht unterhalten ich kann
mich auf nichts konzentrieren doch das
fotografieren und das habe ich halt für
mich entdeckt deshalb wird fotografiert
hat aber auch zur folge wenn ich nicht
am fenster sitze ist das natürlich nicht
möglich und dann eine persönliche
katastrophe
also die sitzplatzwahl ganz entscheidend
frau töne danke dass ihr diese angst mit
uns geteilt haben danke dass sie
mitgemacht haben boxer ist noch bei uns
bei dieser tollen aktion dass wir helfen
ev sein verein zahlt ja frau töne wir
haben uns in der redaktionskonferenz
wirklich intensiv auch mit ihrem fall
befasst und wir sind der meinung dass es
wirklich die vorsatz der muss bekämpft
werden insofern gehören sie jetzt zu den
gewinnern sie haben die chance auf 1000
euro wir werden sie professionell
begleiten wir haben schon mit lufthansa
gesprochen da gibt es diverse termine
zum beispiel im hangar in frankfurter
betreten sie mal dieses angst objekt
flugzeug also wirklich lufthansa und
bild sind da an ihrer seite also
insofern wir stürzen und dieses
abenteuer rein und wir wollen dass sie
endlich ihre flugangst besiegen
freut mich sehr vielen dank und mein
puls rast schon
und auch an herrn rosenauer von unserer
seite noch mal ganz herzlichen dank auch
nochmal so quasi die offizielle
empfehlung dass auch ein paar gläschen
wein mal helfen können europabrücke
freude ist doch auch mal ein
pragmatischer tipp bei vielen herzlichen
dank ihnen für ihre einschätzungen und
in dem sinne stoßen wir an auf den guten
vorsatz von mao töne und kontrollieren
das ganz strenge ab jetzt mit hilfe von
frank ochse ob der eingehalten wird
unser versprechen ja ein frau töne wir
lösen das ja wir sind optimistisch wir
kämpfen und setzen uns für sie ein ganz
toll vielen fragen